what software do I use to make these
videos so I got a question for one of my
Facebook fans love you guys Richard he
wrote me to say hi Evan I just have a
quick question could you please tell me
what programs are used to make the text
videos or could you recommend any other
for example I like the text moving
around in your video decide I would
appreciate your help again thank you
very much Richard so thanks for the
great question Richard for the videos I
have it I have a two-step process now
for that video decide what I usually do
is that's a copy of my newsletter and I
will read my newsletter and I'll record
it into a microphone
using a software tool called audacity
it's a free tool I love it pretty simple
to use I have a Hettie microphone and I
basically just create an mp3 file I then
send that to my video editor producer
Christina who does all the fantastic
work with all of these videos everybody
you see Christina has touched in some
point and so what I'm gonna do is give
her an opportunity to shine and I'm
gonna turn it over to her to explain
what she does with the video once I give
her the mp3 file so Christina over to
you okay guys Rachel thanks for question
but I really need to warn you this will
be my very first tutorial so please
don't judge me very strictly okay let's
do it
Evans next video will be about
salespeople
so here's text that we need to animate
for this kind of videos I use Adobe
After Effects so now it's asking about
settings of my sequence here any just
usual HD so I choose this one also you
can choose here color of your background
black fits for me so okay your work area
divided to a few segments your monitor
you can zoom in/out with your mouse
wheel work in the area and some tools
and settings we need to write in tools I
have it here but you can find them at
window too or press control one I just
got a paste here needed words
no I need to write here let's see
atomium
as you can see it just like it for the
shop so everything is changeable and
very useful you can choose font and how
it should look like
so let put it here I wanted to be at the
center so I need proportional great
okay all fixed I don't need it anymore
here's Evans voice and I need this
Watson her nice
I plan to add some animation present so
I need my cursor to stand right where
what should start typing I need made-up
characters here and I suggested to open
browse presents there's a lots of
options for tax lawyers so you have some
fun so I applied and here sale people
appear nice I can choose when it should
start and then try using using the range
selector
now I'm gonna add more motion at
transforming you I am heading start keys
the position scale and rotation at this
point I want huge out of screens own
lawyer will be a text ad generation of
your sequence and to make it mehendi I
remove for the extra part you need to
press - to see the whole sequence and
plus to zoom it to see who was you're
working at so next line will be this one
Isis how I wanted to look at some colors
huge letters looks nice
how do you think and now again some
animations when you finished the whole
story 'm there will be huge quantity of
lawyers and i want to add some motion to
call lines so i do new composition with
same settings and here i have one and
working in C comp one and I add this
file to my new one so all my lawyers
combined to one and here I can add more
motions who is a less headache
and so time to expert later you will do
it to his hotkeys but for now
file export add to a render here I want
to change format on line item P Davi if
there will be huge file so I prefer this
one in result will the perfect mp4 file
so press random it will take some time
so now I need only to import file to
premiere and synchronize with voice
salespeople ok this one's going to upset
a few people but hear me out
so that's it this program has a huge
opportunities and with some knowledge
you can do everything and I really mean
it everything you just can imagine I
hope you won't lose your interest in
video production and who knows maybe
motion design it will be your next
passion see ya so thanks for the great
question Richard thank you Christina for
that explanation for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below and makes us
want to do more videos like this let me
know what you think leave a comment
underneath if you have a question for
your business or both these videos leave
it in the comment section below I'll
make a video response and if you want to
see more videos like this don't forget
to clip out click on my face and
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon